日本の夏は暑すぎる暑すぎて汗を拭くだけ
でまた汗をかく暑すぎて冷房にも冷房が
必要だ暑すぎてマイン電車に入りたくな逆
に暑すぎてセミが鳴く
いやだから
なくじゃなくてなくだ
痛くて泣いてるんだよあれは暑すぎて水分
補給が発刊に追いつかぬ暑すぎてアイス
クリームがっ最初からただのクリームと熱
すぎて道を歩いていたら他人が家はくれる
暑すぎて
暑すぎて次のセリフ忘れちゃったを暑すぎ
て花火は部屋の中から見る暑すぎて除湿機
が契約の箱に見えて暑すぎてテキサスの人
でも衝撃を受けるやブラックビーンボール
レースに future file なぁ
forever
保険は guards ネームで冊すぎて
もう1回動画のネタにした熱すぎて直径
50センチ以上の帽子じゃないと全く意味
が暑すぎて1日3回以上デオドラントを
つけないとマジでペンぐ化する暑すぎて
部屋着がパンツ一丁だもうあすぎてこの
新しい家の温泉を支えたくならない
めっちゃ高かったのにな暑すぎて一度経験
したらあのテラスなんて湯たんぽレベルだ
暑すぎて冷たければ自販機の偽物コーヒー
も飲みたくなる暑すぎて時々やいサイドの
イースタースピニング挨拶すぎて
eo
珠洲市
暑すぎて本当の道下になった熱すぎてそれ
を冷房なしに kk した埼玉が必然的に
版パンマンになった日本の夏は暑すぎて
その間だけ外国人に対する決まり文句が
日本語上手じゃなくなるこんにちは今日は
発言ですねそうですね
あと
そっか
先にセーターを脱ぐべきだとのっ